el tiroteo de esta noche en una sinagoga
de Jerusalén está ocupado es uno de los
ataques más mortíferos de los últimos
años según la policía israelí el
atacante identificado como un residente
palestino de Jerusalén este llegó sobre
las 8:15 de la noche a una congregación
en nevellakov y allí abrió Fuego contra
creyentes que salían del lugar tras los
rezos de inicio del shabat que
recordemos es el día semanal de oración
para los judíos y un momento de mucha
concurrencia en todas las sinagogas
luego Este joven de 21 años huyó de
lugar hacia el barrio palestino de
beijanina donde murió por disparos de la
policía que ha tildado este ataque de
terrorista y ha estado luego rastreando
la zona en busca de posibles Cómplices
no obstante los Testigos han denunciado
que los oficiales respondieron de forma
tardía y también reprocharon al ministro
de seguridad nacional y Tamara inhibir
que se acercó hasta el lugar y mientras
intentaba hablar se pudieron Escuchar
allí gritos de muerte a los árabes este
que ha sido celebrado tanto por la
yihate islámica Palestina como jamás el
portavoz de este último grupo catalogó
ese tiroteo de una respuesta al crimen
cometido por la ocupación en yening En
referencia a la redada israelí que este
jueves dejó nueve palestinos muertos
entre ellos dos civiles y es que han
sido 48 horas de mucha violencia con la
muerte de otro palestino en la represión
de unas protestas en el Ram el
lanzamiento de cohetes de la yihad desde
gaza el bombardeo israelí en la franja
además de protestas y enfrentamientos
dentro de la propia ciudad vieja de
Jerusalén y a esto se suma que la
autoridad Palestina haya suspendido la
cooperación en seguridad con Israel lo
que supone entre otros que las fuerzas
palestinas no están informadas de las
operaciones israelíes en cis